hello there guys so we have been given
our first look at the star wars obi-wan
kenobi series which is releasing on may
25th with this poster which has given us
our first look at the show we can see
obi-wan in the new outfit here different
to his outfit in revenge of the sith and
different to his outfit in a new hope
you can see obi-wan holding his
lightsaber here in his right hand which
means we will likely see obi-wan in some
type of action used in the lightsaber
possibly against tuscans or even some
other enemies like inquisitors which are
rumored to be in the show we can also
see the twin suns in the poster and i
gotta say overall his new look is just
looking amazing and i cannot wait for
this show now recently there was a new
interview by owen mcgregor talking about
the kenobi show on forbes so i'm going
to speak about that to you guys now so
when mcgregor was asked what he could
share right now about his foolins
playing obi-wan and what it was like
sudden back up in his iconic robe once
again he says oh my gosh well i love
playing him again i mean it's quite
interesting after the experience making
the first three films and living through
sort of a reception in the world which
wasn't always glowing i have to say and
then now meeting the generation who made
those films for the children then and
now people in their late teens or early
20s those people who were kids who made
those films for they loved them to them
they're the star wars films you know for
us it was original films of the 70s but
for them it was our films where their
star was so to step back into his shoes
again now and do a series a whole series
about obi-wan kenobi for those fans it
just makes me really happy when speaking
about the filming process of this new
series mcgregor says it was a great
experience deborah chao directed all the
episodes and she's really good she
directed a couple episodes of the
mandalorian and she's a really great
director she really knows the star wars
world inside out far more than i do we
just had a great time i think it's no
secret that hayden christensen comes
back and we got to place scenes together
as obi-wan kenobi and anakin skywalker
and which is fantastic to work with him
again i'm not going to give away
anything else about the storyline only i
think it's going to satisfy star wars
fans i always felt that was a story
between episode 3 where i finished
playing obi-wan in the movies and
episode 4 where alec guinness is obi-wan
kenobi dobby won kenobi series writers
and deborah and i and everyone i think
we have crafted or they have crafted a
very fine storyline i think people are
going to like it so our mcgregor just
confirmed flashbacks of obi-wan kenobi
and anakin skywalker so i assume these
scenes will take place during the clone
wars and i just can't wait to see
obi-wan and anakin skywalker back on
screen together and knowing that we're
going to get these flashbacks that we
have all wanted it's just i think this
show is going to satisfy everyone as
emily mcgregor has said so what do you
guys think are you guys excited for the
show do you think obi-wan's new outfit
looks good and i excited that we're
going to get flashbacks of obi-wan
kenobi and anakin skywalker let me know
in the comment section below if you
haven't already please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching